this reminds me of a story they had this
man in my town named IC mite and some
people know about this and I've told her
before I think but he used to have
different animal he had ah I might have
told this last week honestly my brain is
so bad you got to know that about me I
don't have a good memory and this man
you know I see Mike he would get water
from different parts of America and we
were good and he would freeze it and we
would go over his to his house and eat
the ice because a lot of us you know we
didn't travel in my neighborhood you
know you were lucky to get to Florida
once you know by the time you were 17 so
I see Mike you know he was getting water
from you know he was getting water from
Georgia he was getting water from you
know he had a couple of buckets come
down from from Missouri you know he had
a couple of he had like six gallons or
something somebody you know somebody
sold them that was from Branson I mean
this dude was getting water from some
really neat places and so we he would
freeze it and we would go over there and
he would put it in those ice trays and
stuff or just do a big block he put it
in those ice trays and put the
toothpicks in it and after we freed we
go over there and eat it and talk about
the area you know just fantasize and
just be imaginative about oh well wonder
what it was like you know to you know
this water tastes like maybe they had
skiers going through it or you know
maybe they had on like people having a
picnic by the banks or whatever you know
we would just use our imaginations and
think about the ice and to try and taste
different realities that could have been
nearby the water before it had come to
us when it was in its natural habitat
and so anyhow you know sometime he would
get a big you know he'd just freeze it
in a big chunk and you know it would
almost be like a luau you know we just
chip off pieces of ice and just you know
have a little bit of Lake Mead or you
know some I don't know if he ever got
anything foreign you know but he got
some you know I don't think he ever got
any like lake titikaka or anything like
that but you know he'd have the normal
Lake Pontchartrain or something from you
know Lake Borgne different stuff but
maybe from like on
Theriault something like that one time
but anyhow that was good stuff we would
have that well I see Mike he took some
ass at one time because a lot of bad LSD
would come through the south and the
kind of [ __ ] were you know the next week
suddenly everybody's you know you know
everybody just kind of like their their
net you know people were wearing vests
I remember or one time everybody bought
a bunch of cowboy boots after some acid
came through see were like ooh you know
that kind of left people a little bit
feeling a little bit country or
different things you know you'd have
people you know some acid would come
through and next thing you know
everybody would be doing art work in
their yard or something just wheat you
know [ __ ] where you know the acid was
kind of affecting everybody as a group
well I see Mike got a couple bad hits a
couple of bad squares of that [ __ ]
paper magic and he had this I he quit
doing nice and he put all his money in
the livestock because his daddy had left
him about eight hundred dollars when he
died so he put all his money in a
livestock and he bought a bunch of
cattle or large animals one of them I
think was a fat horse that had a bad you
know it had been somebody kind of
scalped it and so it didn't have like a
tail but it looked like a cowboy
you know what I'm saying similar animals
and he fed them all a bunch of stuff and
he was gonna have him all poop at the
same time and this just goes back to
your story a little bit care about
animal bowel movements but where he was
gonna have him all [ __ ] at the same time
so he sold tickets around town you know
he had it in you know he could seat
about 40 he had some old bleachers out
there so we all going up there to watch
the big [ __ ] you know everybody's fired
up and people are drinking and
everything and some people even [ __ ]
out in the distance and everybody's
waiting for these animals all the [ __ ]
at once and you thinking to yourself huh
that's creepy I would never watch that
but right now you're still listening to
the story and you're also thinking man I
I wonder how this went so therefore you
would watch that because your brains
still hanging around isn't it so you
know it's coming time where everybody's
expecting you know 8:45 or whatever all
these animals are gonna bust out their
ass
and everything at the same time you know
kind of not really a fireworks but you
know something exciting almost a little
bit biblical but then next thing you
know one of the animals got scared you
know because I think a car alarm went
off or something somebody had a son fire
one of the son fire cars and basically
if you ever owned a son fire I think was
like a Pontiac Sunbird or son fire the
only thing that the car did was the
battery would die and the alarm would go
off I don't even think they were that
you could drive them the battery died
and then the alarm would go off which
was ironic because you needed the
battery to run the alarm but those son
fires man that's all something one of
those went off anyhow one of these
animals and I don't know what it was it
could have been a you know some
something with the deformity it could
have been a [ __ ] it could have been a
giraffe with a you know with Down
syndrome I don't know what you know what
was going on at the time with but one of
these animals took off and people were
like oh [ __ ] this isn't good you know
and they had a man who had been in a war
or who just owned artillery okay
and he took oh he had a grenade a real
grenade and you know sometimes you hear
about grenades and well sometimes you
don't well this is a time when you hear
about it this man through I don't know
if he had a flashback like somebody was
escaped and this was the enemy or
something and I've never even seen a cow
run but this cow was running if it was a
cow and this man threw a [ __ ] grenade
bra and from looking at this dude
and I know him you know I don't want to
sound won't say his full name but first
name Gary but spelled ger ry so I'll
give those clues if somebody from my
town is listening and some people call
him mr. Gary and I never called him that
but anyhow
Gary throw this grenade and I'm thinking
no way Gary's gonna he don't look like a
man that's very accurate and I'll be
damned boy if Gary couldn't [ __ ]
start a barbecue from 300 feet away with
a damn grenade fascinating so you know
not cool and I'm not the kind of guy who
glorifies
kind of stuff I don't think animal
cruelty is good this is before they had
animal cruelty this is 20 years ago when
animals and humans were still fighting
each other a lot and not seeing eye to
eye but that [ __ ] went off boy and so
that's where I'm from if you want to
know where I'm from that's where I'm
from
so don't people act like are you from
here that's where I'm from
all right evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one